pour le moment vous pouvez toujours
faire comme moi c'est à dire atrassi
librement à une terrasse de café que
vous soyez vacciner ou pas cela dit plus
pour très longtemps puisque si la loi
est promulguée dans les délais annoncés
et bien à partir du 9 août pour accéder
à ce type d'établissement
il vous faudra présenter ce fameux qr
code qui prouve que vous êtes bien
détenteurs d'un pass sanitaire sauf que
pour certaines personnes
cela va s'avérer plus compliquée que
prévu c'est le cas notamment pour les
femmes enceintes jusqu'à récemment
voici ce qu'ils étaient préconisées par
les autorités sanitaires le conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
recommande la vaccination de toutes les
femmes enceintes avec ou sans
comorbidités contre lakovic 19 et ce à
partir du deuxième trimestre de
grossesse
sauf que depuis les règles ont changé et
les femmes enceintes doivent désormais
se faire vacciner le plus tôt possible
en dehors de ces situations qui
concernent donc potentiellement quelques
centaines de français
il n'y a aucune contre indication aux
vaccins arn messagers ni la grossesse
premier semestre ni la grossesse dernier
trimestre alors on ne va pas revenir sur
les raisons de ce revirement
ce qu'il faut regarder ici c'est la date
à laquelle par le ministre de la santé
le 20 juillet pour un pass sanitaire qui
doit rentrer en vigueur le 9 août
en clair le gouvernement a laissé moins
de trois semaines aux femmes enceintes
dans leur premier trimestre pour se
faire vacciner et obtenir leurs passes
annie terre et c'est bien ce que
déplorent les principales concernées
que vais-je faire pendant mes vacances
avec mon conjoint et ma soeur qui
m'accompagne et qui eux sont vaccinés
les regarder manger au restaurant et
attendre sur la plage avec un sandwich
je suis déjà nous et eux et je vais me
retrouver à faire la queue toutes les 48
heures environ
parfois sous le soleil en plein
quatrième vague avec des personnes
potentiellement infectées et un risque
accru de devenir cas contacts et ou
infectés peut-on m'expliquer comment une
femme enceinte qui peut potentiellement
se faire vacciner maintenant peut avoir
son pass sanitaires pour les vacances
c'est techniquement impossible
nous sommes les oubliés de l'été
d'autant que malgré ce que dit olivier
ferrand certains professionnels de santé
déconseille toujours au refusent
carrément de vacciner les femmes
enceintes de moins de trois mois des
femmes enceintes qui devront donc passer
un test pcr pour se
andres alors rendez-vous d'obstétrique
puisque la loi prévoit que le pass
sanitaire est obligatoire dans les
établissements de santé en cas de soins
programmés
autant dire que cela va compliquer le
suivi de leur grossesse
outre les femmes enceintes les
collégiens de moins de 12 ans se trouve
également dans une zone grise n'ont pas
accès à la vaccination et pourtant ils
devront quand même passé au cours à
distance si l'on un cas dans leur classe
et vu qu'en 6ème la majorité des élèves
à moins de 12 ans on peut s'attendre à
de nombreuses fermetures de classes ce
qui pénalisera aussi les élèves qui eux
ont bien été vaccinées il ya aussi la
question de la vaccination des expatriés
orieux le problème des vaccinés avant le
3 mai date avant laquelle le qr code
n'existait pas et qu'il faut récupérer
auprès de la personne qui a réalisé
l'injection bref tout un tas de
situations dans lesquelles les français
sont toujours dans l'expectative